there seems to make us all green with
envy and our government having weathered
the storm better than the rest of Europe
Germans are already out on busy streets
that look increasingly normal except for
the masks and now they're cautious
Chancellor says they're ready to go a
stage further I would say the current
infection numbers mean we have the
pandemic under control to some extent
but that's always a snapshot with more
contact we need to see whether it stays
that way we are now entering a phase
where a lots more contact will take
place than before football stadiums
empty for weeks will soon start seeing
games again matches without fans behind
closed doors or geister spilling
literally ghost games in German but the
Bundesliga becomes the first European
major league back in business
to the relief of millions hungry for
live games to watch a game if under some
strict conditions the bullet supplements
Afghani I know that the relevant people
in the Bundesliga clubs will do
everything in their power to create a
safe situations the players who behave
irresponsibly should face consequences
Germany is easing its lockdown gradually
all shops are now reopening museums and
restaurants but with social distancing
still in place one household will now be
able to meet with another but no mass
gatherings after week stuck at home some
remain nervous about relaxing the rules
for football and elsewhere Ben Daggett a
tomato I am a bit divided it is
important that the people who work in
the clubs or stadiums can go back to
work especially in the smaller clubs but
the rest of us are having to do reduced
working hours in other businesses yes
Megan I don't really care either way
whether they play or don't play they are
playing alone with no spectators they
should do what they like but observers
say over the last week or so Germany has
seen a shift in public opinion and a
growing confidence about easing the
lockdown 60% of the pupils said this was
long overdue or this is coming just on
time and around 40% said this is coming
charlie so you could say it's Dave
definitely
a mixed mixed picture just a few days
ago though we were seeing numbers of 90%
of the population supporting especially
angular marker and very tough measures
authorities will reimpose restrictions
if infections rise again but the country
that led the way in controlling the
virus is ahead of the pack again the
rest of Europe is watching hoping
Germany's return to some kind of normal
will allow the rest of us to do the same
Dominic Waghorn Sky News